INTRO:
Do you
know who was the first person to
hit a net worth of $200 billion?
If you follow the billionaire’s list closely,
you’d probably guess Jeff Bezos or Elon Musk.
But, one financier named Bill Browder has
been claiming that this title actually goes
to Vladimir Putin who apparently hit the mark
nearly 7 years ago. This is quite ironic given
that his official presidential salary is only
8.8 million roubles per year or about $130,000.
Even if he were to save his entire salary every
year, it would take him 2 million years to hit
$200 billion. Even with compound growth of
10% per year, it would take him 125 years.
But I don’t think any of us are stupid enough
to believe that the presidential compensation
is Putin’s true source of wealth. In fact, the
reason that he’s not listed on Forbes or Bloomberg
is because he’s believed to have sourced most of
his wealth through illegal avenues. So, here’s
how Vladimir Putin managed to accumulate $200
billion and become the modern-day Tsar of Russia.
GROWING UP IN SOVIET RUSSIA:
Taking a look back, Vladimir Putin was born
on October 7, 1952, in Leningrad, USSR,
or modern-day Saint Petersberg, Russia. He was
the youngest of three children born to Vladimir
Spiridonivich Putin and Maria Ivanovna Putina.
Putin didn’t have much experience getting along
with his siblings though as both of them
had passed away before he was even born.
One of his older brothers, Viktor, had actually
passed away during the siege of Leningrad when
the Nazis occupied the city for nearly 3 years.
And Viktor was just one of 1 million civilian
and military casualties during the siege. You
would think that such an experience would leave
a sour taste in the family’s mouth, but Putin’s
family was actually extremely patriotic. In fact,
many of his family members served political and
military roles. His grandmother, for instance,
was a personal chef for Vladimir Lenin and Joseph
Stalin. Similarly, two of his uncles gave their
lives on the eastern front during World War 2. And
Putin’s father was a conscript in the Soviet Navy
who served until he was severely wounded. Given
that Putin was born well after World War 2,
he didn’t experience any of these events, but I’m
sure his family told him all about it. Anyway,
Putin would end up attending school No. 193 which
was the local school near his home. At school, one
of his favorite tasks was reading books about Karl
Marx and Vladimir Lenin, and as he grew older,
he also started to spend some time learning sambo
and judo. Moving onto high school, Putin would
attend Saint Petersburg High School, and one of
the most valuable things he learned there was
how to speak German. He would later perfect these
skills, and he’s thought to be quite fluent today.
Anyway, moving into college, Putin would
spend 5 years in Leningrad State University
and earned his law degree in 1975. While
at university, Putin became friends with
a business law professor named Anatoly Sobchak,
who will become quite important later on in the
story. Around the same time, Putin was forced
to join the communist party of the Soviet Union.
It’s not clear how exactly Putin felt about this.
When he was a kid, he was one of the only kids
who didn’t join the Young Pioneer organization
which is exactly what you think it is. Also,
Putin would go on to claim that communism is quote
“a blind alley, far away from the mainstream of
civilization.” So, I’m not sure if Putin would’ve
joined the communist part out of free will, but he
definitely wasn’t going to leave out of free will.
And that brings us into Putin’s days at the KGB.
KGB SPY:
After graduating from law school, Putin
enrolled in the KGB and started his training.
If you’re not familiar with the KGB, it
was the Soviet Union’s intelligence agency
or basically their FBI/CIA. Putin’s
first role after training was within
the Second Chief Directorate which primarily
focused on collecting counterintelligence.
This didn’t last for long though as he would soon
be transferred over to the First Chief Directorate
where he was tasked with monitoring foreigners and
consulates. Putin completed such menial tasks for
nearly a decade until September of 1984 when he
was invited to complete further training at the
Yuri Andropov Red Banner Institute. After this
additional training, Putin was sent to Dresden,
East Germany which is where he got his reputation
for being a badass KGB spy. The story goes that
Putin worked as an undercover translator and that
he was involved in crazy events. For example,
one story suggests that Putin helped protect
the integrity of the Soviet Union during the
collapse of the Berlin Wall. Apparently, he
saved the files of the Soviet Cultural Center,
and he burned secret KGB files located in Dresden.
But, many journalists suggest that this is not
what happened at all. Masha Gessen, for example,
claims that even in Dresden, Putin was mainly
limited to menial tasks. Masha suggests that Putin
spent most of his time collecting press clippings
most of which were useless to the USSR. Even one
of Putin’s KGB colleagues, Vladimir Usoltsev,
agrees that they didn’t accomplish anything too
praiseworthy. Some other journalists suggest that
this is just a cover to hide how involved Putin
was with the KGB, but most of the evidence would
suggest otherwise. For example, remember how
Putin burned a bunch of files in Dresden? Well,
Germany was able to retrieve most of the
important files that he apparently burned.
Also, it’s not like Putin cleverly left the KGB
right before the collapse of the USSR. The KGB
actually forced him to resign from active service
after Dresden because they felt that they couldn’t
trust his allegiance. Back in Leningrad,
Putin continued to help with KGB recruiting,
but as soon as the coup against the Soviet
president began, Putin fully resigned from the KGB
on August 20, 1991, and the USSR would
end up collapsing just a few months later.
ENTERING POLITICS:
Now that Putin was out of a job, he decided
to rekindle his friendship with the professor
from college, Anatoly Sobchak, and this
couldn’t have been better timing. You see,
with the fall of the Soviet Union, Sobchak was
trying to secure a position in politics. Putin
helped Sobchak throughout the campaign trail
and he quickly became one of Sobchak’s most
trusted allies. Sobchak would go on to win the
election and he became the first democratically
elected mayor of St. Petersburg. As gratitude
for all of Putin’s help on the campaign trail,
Sobchak would appoint Putin as his advisor on
international affairs. While this was a great
start for Putin in politics, it didn’t take him
long to leave Sobchak in the dust. On June 28,
1991, Putin was promoted to head of external
relations of the Mayor’s Office, and this is
when he would spark up his first controversy. It
was revealed that Putin had used his powers to
approve the export of $93 million worth of metals
in return for foreign food aid that never came.
After the news broke, investigators
actually recommended that Putin be fired,
but this never unfolded because Putin
simply had too much public support.
American presidents often struggle to crack
the 50% approval rating threshold. But, Putin
has crushed this milestone throughout his entire
career. In fact, even with the Ukraine situation,
Putin’s approval rating currently sits at 71%.
From an outside perspective, this might be a bit
confusing as Putin often comes off as a corrupt
merciless ruler. But most Russians wouldn’t want
anyone else in Putin’s place.
RISE TO PREMIERSHIP:
The key to Putin’s popularity
is twofold. The first reason
is that ever since the Soviet Union dissolved,
the financial situation of the average Russian has
exponentially improved. In fact, the average
monthly income has grown nearly 100x. Now,
it’s not clear how much of this is
actually due to Putin and how much
is simply due to a more capitalistic economy,
but a lot of Russians associate Putin’s rise to
power with their own financial rise leading them
to pledge their support. The second reason for
Putin’s overwhelming support is that he was the
strong leader that many Russians felt they needed.
In the 1990s, many Russians felt that their
power and dominance on the world scene had
fallen off a cliff ever since the 1960s. And
given Putin’s intense patriotism and iron fist,
it seemed like he was the right man to return
Russia to its former glory. And if you don’t
believe me, just take a look at 130,000 people
singing the Russian national anthem with Putin.
Clearly, this is not a guy
that’s lacking public support.
Anyway, Putin leveraged this public support
to continue moving up the political ladder.
In 1996, he was promoted to deputy chief of the
presidential property management directorate. Two
years later, he was promoted to First Deputy Chief
of Staff of the Presidential Executive Office.
And in 1999, the president of Russia, Boris
Yeltsin, chose Putin to be the Prime minister of
Russia. And when Yeltsin stepped down from being
president, he nominated Putin to be his successor.
Putin would go on to win the 2000
election garnering 53% of the vote,
and his popularity has only grown since. For
example, he won the 2018 election with 76.69%
of the votes. To put that in perspective, the only
American presidents who won a larger percentage of
the popular vote were James Monroe and George
Washington. With such overwhelming support,
it’s clear that Putin isn’t
going anywhere anytime soon.
BILLIONAIRE PUTIN:
So, we’ve covered how Putin got to the
top politically, but how did Putin get
to the top financially? After leaving the KGB,
Putin says that he considered becoming a taxi
driver to earn extra money, so things
were looking quite bleak. But today,
he’s potentially the richest person in the world,
so, what happened? Well, like all billionaires,
his primary source of wealth is assets starting
with stakes in companies. Putin is speculated to
have massive stakes in a handful of oil giants.
This includes a 37% stake in Surgutneftegaz,
a 4.5% stake in Gazprom, and at least a
75% stake in Gunvor. All these companies
are extremely private and some of them have even
rejected the notion that Putin is a shareholder,
but critics argue that this is just an attempt
to cover up his involvement with these companies.
After all, it’s highly unlikely that Putin paid
for these stakes. The more likely scenario is
that he was given these stakes in return for
political favors whether that be easier regulation
or government contracts. Similarly, Putin also has
a vast portfolio of real estate holdings including
20 different palaces and villas. And we’re not
talking about real estate worth tens of millions
or even hundreds of millions. Some of these
holdings individually clock in at over $1 billion.
Putin of course denies owning these estates,
and it may be true that he doesn’t directly own
these properties. But, it’s speculated that
Putin owns all these stakes and properties
through various proxies. One of Putin’s
political colleagues, Stanislav Belkovsky,
suggests that Putin is worth at least $40 billion,
and in terms of an upper bound, he has no clue.
So, Putin is no doubt extremely wealthy, but
he doesn’t really like to show off his wealth.
It seems that his wealth is more for himself
to enjoy as opposed to something that he shows
off to the media. Something that Putin is proud
to show off to the world though is his power.
PUTIN TODAY:
By now, I’m sure all of you guys are
familiar with the Ukraine situation.
It looks like Putin is invading
Ukraine to quote on quote “teach
them a lesson.” So far, it doesn’t seem like his
actions have really cost him much public support
within Russia. But this could quickly change
if things turn sour. Many western countries are
starting to place sanctions on Russia and limiting
their abilities, but I don’t think this really
makes a difference given that Putin fully expected
this from the very beginning. In the meantime,
Putin feels that he’s the wealthiest man not only
in Russia but in the entire world not in terms
of money, though that may also be true, but in
terms of trust. Putin asserts that Russians have
entrusted him with the leadership of Russia
for over two decades, and that right there,
will forever be his greatest wealth. Are you guys
fans of Putin or do you think he’s a douchebag
for invading Ukraine? Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re a fan of the Russian
national anthem. And of course, consider checking
out our international channels to watch our videos
in other languages and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.